[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know that the state of politics
is tense and degraded
when a friend of mine has to flee the
country for his life
because of all the threats he's getting
from leftist militants i can't
i actually can't believe no matter how
crazy things have gotten that i have to
utter that statement
in america in 2021 but i do my friend
andy noe is currently in the united
kingdom
because he is target number one for some
of the most prominent leftist
terrorists in the country um most of
whom
work under the banner of antifa and he
has a new book out
which i think is sort of the the book on
the topic
the book is unmasked inside antifa's
radical plan to destroy democracy
uh order the book now get it while you
still can i'm sure it'll it'll be
de-platformed or at least suppressed by
by big tech and by the
liberal establishment andy i'm glad that
i'm sorry that you're out of the country
right now but i am glad that you're safe
thank you for having me on michael my
pleasure i
i want to talk about some news that uh
antifa has
broken i mean they didn't report the
news they actually broke things and
therefore that is the news
antifa took over this hotel in olympia
washington
over the past week they appear to have
taken hostages
some staff fled some guests sheltered in
place
this is not just uh you know running
around making a nuisance in the streets
this is
this is the sort of thing you'd see in a
third world dictatorship
yes this is what happens in somalia and
yemen for example the
terrorists will target hotels so on
sunday
a group of antifa took over the red line
in downtown
olympia washington state that's the
state capitol
and uh according to the statement that
was put out
the city uh staff were assaulted
that they witnessed these militants
bringing in hatchets
knives and batons um within
so this was just uh over the weekend
police did
eventually respond in large numbers to
get these militants out but this really
should have been
uh international news um just
how shocking that they i mean just with
re it's becoming routine for them now to
just take over
territory or buildings and claim that
upstairs
and i believe this is the first time
they've done it to a building
where dozens of people were victimized
you know you're you've become i guess
one of the last
journalists in america by that i mean
you are going in covering stories that
other people don't want to cover as you
say
this should have been international news
it wasn't the liberal establishment
is basically covering for antifa many
people in the liberal establishment have
said
antifa is just an idea
something tells me you're not fleeing
the country because of the threats
you've gotten from
just an idea this is real people who are
committing real violence
yeah i think the see so that i ideology
statement that came from
president biden then during a
presidential debate
it was first set by the head of the fbi
christopher wray
and that statement in itself is not
incorrect
but it it needed to be followed up so
in addition to being an ideology it's
also movement and networks of
organizations now that third part is
particularly important because that's
how they carry out
acts of domestic terrorism and
it's not just theory you know it's one
thing if they were only distributing
their extremist literature
but this literature then is also coupled
with pamphlets and booklets
describing actually on how to claim and
siege territory how to
make homemade bombs um how to make
molotov cocktails and i think because
the antifa have had essentially
cover by the mainstream and legacy press
people don't even realize
how extreme they are i mean think about
it so
we just now had the weekend of them see
uh seizing a hotel where people were
inside and bringing
allegedly weapons blunt force weapons
and knives
and hatchets but that was just one day
we had
throughout 2020 in my home city of
portland
month after month of the month of
nightly right so everything that
happened
on the 6th of january at the capitol
hill siege all that
and more happened day after day after
day in my city
and the establishment left and the media
left gave him cover for that
at best they were silent at worst some
of them actually even support
encouraged people to donate to some of
these crowdfunds that would
um give supplies to these rioters or
contribute to their bail funds so that
those who happen to get arrested are
just
back on the street asap this is the the
aspect of it that that
still confuses me a little bit though
it's i think it's becoming clearer and
clearer and your book is helping to
explain why that is
antifa is this kind of group of
anarchists
and communists who want to tear down the
system they're burning down buildings
they've burned down
government buildings they've taken over
hotels as we've discussed
why does the establishment left
which owns many of these buildings and
which you know operates within this
formal system
why are they covering for the people who
seem to want to tear the system down
you're right they we have the
establishment
establishment left giving coddling
this beast that i think is now too big
to slay so
on inauguration day for example in
portland the
antifa destroyed the headquarters of the
democrat
party office in portland um but i think
the reason why this
allyship had developed was particularly
um so in response to the surprise win of
trump in 2016
uh those who either out of ignorance or
zealotry
actually did believe that this was a
sign of ascendant fascism in the us
and so the excuse and in some cases even
encouraged the most extreme
elements of the far left like antifa to
come right into the mainstream left and
that's exactly what happened
the political violence from antifa
was accepted and tolerated in many urban
centers to the point of where
for example in portland and seattle's
political street violence is routine
it's not
it doesn't even really make the news
there when people are smashing up
businesses or starting fires
um people gotten used to it over the
years and this was allowed to happen
ostensibly
under the banner of anti-fascism and
anti-racism
but all it is is it's violent extremism
mass
under social justice well this this is a
great point because
very often the left projects and accuses
its opponents of doing what it itself is
doing and so what we saw with the rise
of trump
during that time you had the left begin
to
elide say mainstream conservatives
and radical neo-nazis whatever and
you know whenever the occasional
skinhead crops up the mainstream
conservatives say oh yeah we're
we're not that we don't agree with that
but the left no longer makes that
distinction they don't even use the
different words anymore
you'll notice they don't even use this
term alt-right or what
you know whatever the term was that
becomes completely
drained of meaning now what the left is
saying is that
effectively 75 million americans who
some odd
75 million who voted for trump are
fascists they're nazis they're no
different than hitler
right so they're erasing that
distinction when in fact there are many
distinctions on the right
but for the left the distinction between
these radicals like antifa
who are going out and giving brain
hemorrhages to people
such as yourself there really is much
less of a distinction between them
and the mainstream left who has been
coddling them and encouraging them
now for years yeah so what's allowed
antifa to become
so empowered from a fringe movement you
know a phenomenon that it's actually
destabilizing forts in some cities
is because of this um
excuse that the less gives in that
the threat from the right it's not even
just
breadth from the far right it's they're
casting this wide net of fascism
over trump supporters even people for
example
uh who went to the capitol to listen to
trump speaker had nothing to do with
riots these people are now also being
called domestic terrorists
um they're essentially they've
mainstream tenants of antifa's ideology
and it comes down to as you mentioned a
moment ago antifa
are anarchist communists and
from the original antifa to today and by
the original antifa i'm referring to
the paramilitary antifa of the
german communist party in the interval
years that was the first one
in the group that contemporary have to
take inspiration and a
direct lineage from um it's
it's under that ideology that gives them
um in their minds the
justification for setting fires to
buildings when people inside it
bashing people on the head with crowbars
and bricks
um and in my case in 2019 a person with
a camera
they actually punched me repeatedly in
the head until i had a brain humber
and they all actually think that they
are doing something just and noble and
that's
really what makes them really dangerous
because they see i mean they say it
themselves that they will do
do this all by any means necessary
opposing fascism
and uh that if if necessary they will
kill and they have killed
and they've gotten themselves killed in
the process of carrying out attacks as
well which i document in the book
right you know it's it's kind of
ironic i guess or it's just a it's an
inversion of what we used to see which
is in the traditional culture
you had the west was a christian culture
right it was christendom
and christianity posits the incarnation
of the perfect good
in christ and we're all kind of evil but
you know you have this incarnation of
the perfect good
which can lead us toward redemption and
in leftism which kind of
flips that on its head you don't really
have any good and you kind of get rid of
all all those
all those old notions but you do have
the incarnation of
pure perfect evil and that takes the
form of
fascism or nazism or or hitlerism or
whatever right i mean
basically all the references come back
to world war ii
and this incarnation of of perfect evil
in
the form of fascism and so if you can if
you can
tie your opponent to fascism if you know
you can make your opponent literally
hitler
then that justifies doing anything so
you get a mild-mannered journalist like
you
one of the for people who don't know you
personally one of the sort of most
mild-mannered nice polite people that i
i am friends with goes out in antifa and
they say
you and you know are literally hitler
and we're going to bash your head in
luckily you escaped with your life but
but
all the while you have guys like jake
tapper for instance at cnn
who when when the the white identitarian
guy
richard spencer got punched in the face
he was participating in these kind of
jokes saying well it's the american
tradition to punch nazis
in now nobody's defending these guys
like richard spencer
but surely i think we can all
acknowledge that we shouldn't have
vigilantism in the streets
guys going around sucker-punching and
and committing political violence
right but now you have the mainstream
left defending that because of this
kind of broad category of fascism
yeah that was my concern several years
ago when people on the mainstream
left for celebrating these needs about
richard spencer being assaulted
now i took issue with it not because i
like richard spencer or stand up for
what he believes in
it's nothing like that it's about the
principle
or this norm that we do not
solve political disagreements through
violence i mean that's sort
of the base human instinct and a lot of
societies around the world still solve
their issues that way
and the fact that non-violence uh
between citizens is the norm in the u.s
is a huge accomplishment and now we're
undoing that that undoing was being
celebrated because
um you know it's easy to dislike or hate
somebody like richard spencer but then
again at that time that label of who is
the fascist is being a pride
applied so broadly that it included just
anybody who
uh is critical of communism it's
critical of antifa
is critical uh social justice extremism
all of us are labeled fascists and
therefore worthy
of their acts of violence and assaults
and intimidation
i mean i've had people show up to my
home
multiple times all this has been
reported to police they routinely write
around the city of portland where
i lived murder and you know kill andy no
and so
and all this is being reported to police
and they don't do anything so
you know the conditions that gave rise
to antifa
really had very little to do with trump
that was just
pre-tax for them to mainstream their
extremism and now with trump out of the
picture you can really see that
their actions are no different they're
rioting the same
they're victimizing the public in the
same way they're attacking
democrat institutions in the same way
i do want to touch on the portland of it
all as you mentioned
they they seem to cluster around there
they go after you personally there in
your city
what is it about the pacific northwest
they you know they took over this hotel
in washington state
why i mean i know that antifa is spread
out throughout the country
we've seen them in washington dc and all
over the place but but why
what is it about portland that seems to
have attracted so many of these
militants
so as i write in the book um the origin
of american antifa in its really
organized form as we see today did start
in portland through
one of the cells called rose city antipa
which is the anti-foam portland i think
the establishment of this cell is
significant because then
once they already had a blueprint to
radicalize recruit and train members and
prospective members
that could really be easily applied to
new auxiliary groups that
established in neighboring cities so
what you happen is it just becomes sort
of a once
the apparatus is built just to get
stronger and stronger because then now
riots that happen for example in
portland don't just
involve the antifa from portland the
antifa from seattle
from olympia from eugene from corvallis
will come up
and vice versa as well so you have what
is in absolute numbers of relatively
small number of militants
being much bigger than just
a city problem i think all of this
underscores the point
that antifa is not just an idea it's an
i
sure it's an idea but it's not just an
idea if it were just an idea
you'd see it maybe evenly spread out
throughout the place but no it involves
real people actually training actually
exercising violence in real places
and where they cluster more people are
going to come as well
it's not just philosophy there's a
history to this
also you know one thing that's kind of
funny with the antifa guys if you want
to use the word funny to describe these
terrorists
is the way they talk and the way they
write
they sound like the pink hat wearing
campus radicals you know they talk about
intersectionality and gender theory and
you'd expect them to be kind of wimpy
you know in the in the
the ideologies they're espousing but
they're not they're not
little special snowflakes they're armed
with guns and machetes and bats
how do we reconcile this this idea that
all the you know people
spouting these silly ideas are so wimpy
well
they look pretty tough to me yes i'm
really glad you pointed that out because
there is this
misconception on the right that antifa
are just soy boys who are weak and winky
i mean it doesn't really matter about
their physical strength these are people
who bring
gums homemade explosives incendiary
devices
uh hatchets hammers two
riots and again and they use these
weapons against
people as well and so and they've killed
so it doesn't matter if they're weak and
you know it doesn't take much strength
to fire
a pistol or a rifle for example or to
stab somebody with a knife as they did
in
portland this past summer um so we're
underestimating
even the right is underestimating them i
think
in addition to the organized violence
the philosophy in theory that
that is the basis for their movement and
ideology is really crucial
because it calls for not just um
destruction and violence it actually
the main goal of it is to abolish the
united states so like in their world
view
they cannot establish their communist
anarchist utopia
made up of communes until the united
states is destroyed
so you can see um what happens when the
political theory if you will is put into
a practice
look at chad's the capitol hill
autonomous zone i write about my time
undercover there in the book
it is an an area once they claimed it
and claimed as a sovereign
territory separate from the us
immediately
it devolves into murders homicides
attempted rapes violence night after
night after night
um infighting even even though they
claimed to be horizontally organized and
not to have any leadership
there were figures immediately who rose
up and were vying to be the warlords
of this territory that's what their
ideology leads to
well of course and and when the chazz
zone
and all these other pseudo states that
they're establishing
when they fail of course we'll be told
that true antifa has never been tried
and they'll try it again and again you
know there does seem to be an
anti-establishment movement on the left
and the right so on the left it's antifa
and blm
on the right they generally are more
peaceful much more peaceful
but there's still a real
anti-establishment
idea cropping up that that this
establishment is corrupt
they're not particularly wise they're
serving themselves they're not serving
the american people this seems to be
getting worse and worse and worse i was
told if joe biden became president
it would be a return to normalcy just
the first week
all of the executive actions radical new
policy coming out of him
even more social strife that doesn't
seem to be the case
you've you've mentioned the end game of
antifa here which is
the total upheaval of the system the
eradication of the united states
what do the next few years look like
you're probably the nation's foremost
leader on antifa
do you have a crystal ball do you have
any prediction on where things go from
here
uh i think it goes where they've been in
the past year
which is that because of weak leadership
in certain urban areas like seattle and
portland
and other cities uh because of
demoralized police departments and
officers leaving in the droves and their
budgets being slashed by the hundreds of
millions
you're going to continue to see an
uptick in crime
and i think the my fear is that this is
leading to
a self-fulfilling prophecy where
antifa seek to
make the public not trust
um in the ability of the state to
provide like for the basic needs you
know just like
peace protection of property rights and
all that which is why these attacks
on on capitol property uh is
i mean there's a lot of meaning behind
it it's not just want and violence
they actually want business owners to
leave
they want the areas to become destitute
so they can go in and
claim to be the replacement for the
state and you know doing that at the
federal level is
i don't think going to happen but you
can really see
uh the carnage that they can wrap in
cities because of the leadership that
turns a blind eye because they actually
think that these people are
anti-fascists
that's what i'm afraid of well you've
seen the rise of so-called no-go zones
in areas in in europe where basically
uh radical islamists came in and and to
sort of
displace the state there and you see the
rise of no-go zones in the united states
where
like the chaz or like many parts of
portland or parts of
parts of washington and uh yeah the fear
is
that things don't seem to be getting
better if anything they seem to be
trending in the wrong direction
one way to arm yourself uh with
facts with the knowledge of of what this
really is and it's going to be very
contrary
to the propaganda you're hearing in the
mainstream press
is to read andy's book unmasked inside
antifa's radical plan
to destroy democracy a really really
important book i'm glad that you were
able to put it out i know antifa is
threatening you even threatening
bookstores that are that are going to
carry
your book so make sure you you order it
now before it's taken down
and andy when it's safe for you to
return
i very much look forward to uh to seeing
you in person
at some time i know we we haven't had a
lot of travel now because of the wuhan
flu
everyone's very afraid of that i'm much
more afraid of the armed leftist
terrorists who are
who are threatening you but i i look
forward to seeing you again in person
i'm sure that this book
is going to climb the best seller charts
in the meantime
thank you so much michael great to see
andy we'll we'll see you
[Music]
soon
[Music]
you